friends buddy and Mike hey had multiple
friends in what you are you have that
problem that is because i have four eyes
it's peter and then this painter
whenever you go to games could be a hunk
home safe we have one more segment on
this show where we take something which
is in a package Oh taking ahead of the
package yeah this package I didn't know
about stuff I know we got a package this
morning do you know a package this is I
know what package it is tell mike well
packaged the HTC vive ohio sorry v.v oh
man the ricky mark viva la vie de vivre
a viva forever apparently so we have an
open we all I've no idea what's in this
we don't even know where we're gonna set
it up yeah so this is so we're going to
just do it I've been told that this is
not this is it's a vibe but it is not
the final product version because the
packaging is likely change and all that
and it's probably the one they've been
giving out to developers recently yeah
so it's probably going to look a little
bit nasty so action yeah put down here
i'll pick pick things at one by one here
is the manual you can customize or not
oil man one sorry Frank case remember
not final packaging this is for review
purposes only tonight six you see
official notarized notes Diane written
though his Ephraim what's-his-face the
man who never responds I don't know is
that I don't think we wrote that but
absolutely had Doug Lombardi that stuck
on but yeah chocolate party rogue days
I'm still not convinced he's a real
person stuck he's written to me email he
wants out church yeah anything to be
before i was in how many females did it
take before you get our spoken okay here
we go this is the first part it's a wall
madness so i can you buy a TV and like
the worst part comes out of the box
first i have to tear this of it and even
if i don't i'm going to post I call that
empty space for video sec you cushion
from the good people of video sec you a
video sec you solutions speaker wall and
ceiling match
you go there you go can mount your
ceiling stand up oh that's actually
surprisingly way okay here's a box it is
vibrant no sovv just stick your head in
the box and that's the headset it just
pops out you wish it was that easy okay
well we got what's enough this is
probably the unit right start here yeah
is the dev kit that's yeah it's okay so
it is a def ken wha you what you unbox
that bad boy okie dokie it's actually
not as heavy as I thought it would be
whoo put it on so you can look like one
of those flying things from the matrix
that's right it's a Rises look like good
news I'm sorry I keep hitting the
microphone ah it's too tight but I don't
care it's so weird this one count at the
camera in front the cow in the front
makes it look like you've got this weird
Cyclops thing I said that and this is
the breakout box which is an HDMI USB 3
receiver type thing so they go yeah you
you just keep that on for the rest of
this we've sort of bear we've sort of
like ruined this unboxing by taking at
the only part anyone cares about but I'm
really interested to see what else is in
here and here's some here's some stuff
here's a that's a power supply cable
don't be cares about that speak for
yourself this is a USB three breakout
cable a station TV what's this it looks
just like it something just a weight
that you put on no that's that's its
padding for the there you go put this
off figured it out put down that's
padding for the inside of the thing yeah
we're gonna need like 20 of these
because that things gonna get real grimy
in this office for us alright let's get
this so this is the final dude that's
what the inside looks like this
you get in the light a little bit here
this is the future people like that yeah
you're watching the future video games
get unboxed right now and then look at
this length of this cable it's huge it's
USB 3 and hdmi yeah cable it looks like
it's about 220 feet maybe you think sure
there you go taking an estimate better
be at least 24 guesstimate yes sir and
here's not a cable all right let's see
what's in here nothing we do believe you
know when you're uh wiping all the filth
off of fear why you're been to a
chiropractor and they have those the
beds you put your face in two but
they've never been going on above us
this feels like that nice it's strangely
appealing yeah do we get the little
cameras where the little cameras I think
they're coming out there sorry by the
way this is not playing for the podcast
audience I apologize so much well do our
best to do visual descriptions of all of
this okay this box feels heavy and I
feel like it's probably the the stuff
you want to want to do that one mic sure
it's a lot more than our big box near as
well
this is eight hundred dollars worth of
hot equipment for those in the chat
wondering about price alright what's in
that one mic on pad asst is how what
they look like hey in Ginza right really
called lighthouses something like that
doesn't look like any light as I've ever
seen look like a dark house nice work
nice one ad did I sit on the floor I
know so these ghosts are lighting here
on an elevated platform or pedestal
whatever you have so that it can sort of
look down upon the room you might even
mounted to the ceiling with your video
sec you premium wall mount thank you
video sec you oh hello oh yes these are
very I haven't held these yes oh no no
okay this is this is the weirdest thing
doctor thing I've ever but what so I get
here let's get a brandy so I've used the
oculus touch stuff yeah which feels a
little bit weird this is what am i doing
it right here you do you do you've
actually gone I mean all you do is you
do it these are the controllers just
hold them there doesn't just stop at the
hole what's the holes Abed uh is this is
not an R rated show right oh no I think
it's virtual reality god it's there all
these little ir emitters okay i believe
on here and these are the the little
lighthouse things are the sensors that
pick up the emitter zand so i imagine
you know I really don't know I think I
could just make up something that's a
total guess anti social gamer said set
phasers to stun yeah they do kind of
look a little bit Oh a nice good night
that's a good click 10 out of 10 and
then this is just like the haptic
feedback thing uh well I wouldn't call
haps optic feedback that term gets
thrown around a lot right it's a
touchpad that I think vibrates a little
bit all right gross yeah you're right
it's been something anyone but ya know
these things uh they work really well
I've used it they have this this grip
sensor that I really like
is that what that is yeah okay so that
has to be like when you're grabbing
things rather than right trigger which
would work but you don't really grab
things by hooking it with your index
finger grip it with your hand right and
so it definitely gives that sensation of
actively grabbing a thing wow that's
cool and then and then firing it at
somebody because all the games are about
shooting things while standing studies
did it give us any any games at this bad
boy uh that's a good question we
purchased this or was this actually
supply this was provided to us by valve
thank you thank you very much valve
which probably mention that those well I
think we also are in the we're gonna
preorder one of these bad boys as well
probably uh yeah I mean we need to get a
few of these in the same way that goes
with the oculus rift because there are a
lot of games coming out at launch and
for one person to test all of them would
be insane yeah it's been you for the
past three years for ganked five I think
yeah we've Scott Butterworth has sort of
picked up some of that he went to valve
but a month ago yang to go there much
cool stuff i think i will be reviewing
most of the launch games for oculus most
of the notable ones anyway let's say
turn you just turn on i heard a beer
button on never touch bed sounds like
one of those old LCD game machines this
is I I cut we're like on a lit set right
here and I literally can't see any life
it's like actually really impressive how
could this is a blocking head all the
light the best sunglasses money can buy
you go yeah can't even see the Sun and
yeah sorry I do we have games to play on
this bad boy then uh I'm sure we will
have access I'm not sure if we have them
at this Center I'd probably via that URL
maybe or something yep cool well there
you go we just unboxed of VV VV virtual
reality thank you so much am I even near
the microphone I got even gentleman yeah